good morning
all right I'm admitting all you ready
all right let's do it
hello everybody
it's always awesome to have a full
waiting room as we're getting started
here so for those of you who are on with
us live
if you go and click on participate at
the bottom of that list of participants
there is an option to invite others you
click on that and it will you can copy
the link to this show and then send it
to your family and friends and say hey
jump on this with me
and they also will be able to hear
askdoc live so we love the fact that we
have so many wonderful people on with us
we love the cameras The Smiling Faces
and around the world
absolutely love it my name is Becca
dukes and I have been granted the
privilege of having this two hours as
the host of ass doc live and again for
those of you who are on with us live if
you have questions for our Dr Wallach go
ahead and find that option to raise your
virtual hand so if you're doing this I
don't always see all of the pictures so
I won't see you raise your physically
hair physical hand but there you go
Rosemary got it thank you Rosemary
um but raise your virtual hand and we'll
be able to see that you have your hand
up with a question
and go through the questions
as the hands are raised so welcome to
askdoc live
so this program is being brought to you
by askdoclive.com
and it is a resource
to help you
get knowledge that empowers
you yourself your community to take your
health into your own hands who has more
interest in making sure that you have
less pain less illnesses
than yourself
we can be our own authority we have our
own best interest in mine and is at the
top of the list or if it's not it should
be folks so in today's program
we're going to be providing information
that is for
informational purposes only
let me turn the sound off I apologize
thank you all right
uh the contents of this program is to
provide information only on the
importance of supplementation and how
your body responds when it has
deficiencies and what you can do
to change that response in a more
positive manner now these statements
that are going to be brought to you
today on this program have not been
evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products discussed
are not intended to diagnose treat cure
prevent any disease and the information
again is for informational purposes only
if you are pregnant nursing or taking
medications please consult your health
care professional before starting on any
supplemental program or even putting a
tomato in your mouth but hey
that's just my opinion because you know
with us today we have a amazing doctor
who has actually been very instrumental
in providing information and even paying
with his own dollars to sue the FDA with
nine victories that have led to the
addition of vital nutrients into foods
and allowing us to be able to distribute
this information to you because folks it
is proven by science to be factual
in the essential need of supplementation
against disease
so we also bring you good news that the
genetic theory which is really good news
to me
this theory has been proven incorrect
the science of epigenetics is the study
of how your own behaviors and the
environment can change the way that your
genes are expressed and with epigenetics
you are an empowered individual and have
more control than you think of your own
health Journey
and we invite you to feel the difference
with the options that are shared in this
program now the testimonies that may be
shared on this program are voluntary
they are not anybody that is a paid
actor to comment and bring any type of
false information and if you are on with
us and you have a factual testimony of
your
amazing experience with what Dr Wallach
has recommended in his protocols please
raise your hand we love to hear those
testimonies as well
now this program again I said is
sponsored by
askdoclive.com but if you are here
because somebody took the time to invite
you and wanted to share this information
with you make sure that you get back
with that person to get more information
especially on ordering
and the first thing you want to do is
thank them for taking the time to share
this program with you if you are
watching this video as a replay on any
of the platforms that we broadcast to
and you would like more information
about the products and there was nobody
specific that shared it with you feel
free to go to the website
askdoglive.com and use the contact us
submit your questions there and one of
our certified holistic health coaches
will get back with you
now to guide us through this journey on
making choices that are empowering to
our own health we are honored to have
one of the founding fathers of
epigenetics
who is also the recipient of the 2011
Claus Schwartz commemorative medal a
lifetime achievement on on natural
medicine and philanthropy
philanthropy I can never get that right
philanthropy from the United Nations in
here with us
to share the best options to obtain or
maintain Optimal Health Dr Joel Wallach
Dr Wallach welcome to askdoc life
okay well thank you Rebecca and thank
you team before you get started Doc
before you get started for those of you
who are on with us live make sure that
you turn that chat option on our amazing
co-host Ruth Ellen Sanchez nissima Omar
and Dr Judy Reynolds they will be
sharing information in that chat that
will help you find
um the names of the products because Dr
wallet doesn't slow down for anybody
um not even me even though I ask him doc
let's talk slower we reach around the
world some of the folks listening this
is not their first language so let's be
kind right
all right Doc it's all yours
my name is Dr Wallach
so I'm going to speak slowly so
everybody can understand me okay okay
cut it in half
okay so any rate epigenetics very very
proud of that it's one of those things
where it's going to have a huge positive
impact here as we as we move forward as
Humanity this is not just a one day deal
this is forever and ever okay
the truth is always the truth
and I want to speak today about a
cholesterol deficiency well you heard me
cholesterol deficiency
and cholesterol deficiencies
have been going on since women wanted to
be beautiful and slim
because what they would do is they would
avoid eating animal fat they would avoid
eating eggs they would avoid eating
anything that had fat in it like Dairy
and butter and and so forth and they
were just Overjoyed when margarine came
along because it wasn't butter and they
would just be so happy
um with
everything that was without animal fat
um you know like uh skim milk and things
like that they were so happy because
they're getting rid of all the animal
fat well in 1910 a disease called
Alzheimer's disease appeared okay we'll
talk about that in a minute it wasn't in
existence very significantly until 1910
and now it's very significant okay
Allison Rosie's and then there's Ms
multiple sclerosis which is a loss of
the white matter of the brain and then
of course when you have the same thing
going on in the spinal cord you get
Guillain-Barre syndrome Parkinson's
disease which is Ms with a lot of
Tremors
demyelinization where everything seems
to fall apart where the white manner of
your brain goes away because 25 of your
brain weight okay is cholesterol 25 of
your spinal cord weight is cholesterol
it's one of those things where you have
to
um be eating it because it's a
consumable item that goes away it just
you don't just take it once and you have
it forever and ever okay you know even
minerals like calcium you have to take
it in every day don't just take it in
once and it lasts you forever okay and
so this is a a constant thing well it's
one of those deals where
um the medical mistake hit big time
okay about a hundred years ago
when doctors made the mistake of saying
oh plaque in the arteries is due to
cholesterol give up cholesterol don't
eat eggs don't eat dairy don't eat
animal fat because that's what's causing
the plaque in your arteries and plugged
arteries and high blood pressure and all
that kind of stuff and everybody
immediately went that direction okay
because doctors said you know doctors
said
and so
then they started getting other things
happening uh about two years ago the
rate of
gain lesbian behavior
um in America was three percent of our
population now it's seven percent it's
more than doubled what is going on here
okay are people that frustrated you know
with you know normal hormones and
everything like that no it's a dietary
deficiency okay because when the uh in
1910 there's very few people had
Alzheimer's disease but now Alzheimer's
disease is a big deal it really got big
in 1960 and especially you know that
point the pharmaceutical industry came
out with statin drugs the lower
cholesterol and everything began to
crash okay and so then just um I don't
know the exact dates here Rebecca may
have the exact dates but this um uh lady
scientist a PhD I believe
um Ivanka
javik okay from Sweden she published an
article okay and the Swedish brain
Institute of publication which was then
put into an American Journal the uh
let's see here the
proceedings the proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences in the USA
so what was this very special
publication
okay well
this um gal did it took an MRI and did
studies
uh on two groups of people one group was
25 straight males and
you see let me back up 25 straight women
and 20 gay males the second group was 25
gay
um uh see here are that lesbian women in
20 straight men okay for a total of 90.
they did MRI studies on them and here's
what they found
foreign
let's see here lesbian
oh oh let's see here let's just start
with homosexual men and straight women
homosexual men and straight women have
equal sized hemispheres of the brain
right and left but the women
um have normal
electrical transmission between the
right and the left brain and also down
the spinal cord and so forth whereas the
homosexual men have a electrical problem
okay it's not the same speed or
efficiency okay and then let's see here
let's go to lesbian women and straight
men okay both of them have larger right
hemispheres and left hemispheres of the
brain but again the lesbian women have
an electrical problem in transmission
from right to left side and also down
the spinal cord
and so this is what's going on okay now
it's one of those things where uh this
MRI was just such a great great study
now
this is one of those things that is
totally preventable unfortunately it's
not reversible because when
when does the part of the brain is
involved with sexuality when does that
part of the brain form
well I went back into embryology and it
turns out somewhere between three and a
half weeks and four weeks of pregnancy
the neural tube begins to form and
that's when the brain is farming if the
mother's been avoiding fats animal fats
and cholesterol for
six months uh five years ten years
trying to stay skinny and slim to be
beautiful
um guess what the embryos can be cheated
and the brain is not going to form
correctly okay and so this is what's
happening here and just it blows my mind
because of the MRI we've been able to
understand this okay
and this is not a reversible thing but
it is a preventable thing it is a
preventable thing now let's look at
something like Alzheimer's disease
Alzheimer's disease there's no known
um
anatomical changes with all kinds of
biochemical changes and the levels again
of the
um cholesterol in the brain is way down
and Alzheimer's disease MS gambarre
syndrome Parkinson's disease and
demolinization and you always hear me
talk about eating three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks which I had this morning
for breakfast but also
in addition to your 90 essential
nutrients I also want you to take our
I-26 or I-26 okay is a wonderful product
and you read on the back of the label
list
supplemental facts it provides 25 of
your daily requirements of cholesterol
now how many people are saying on their
products that you have a requirement for
cholesterol and they're bragging about
having 25 of your daily requirements in
cholesterol okay our I-26 does that it
comes in powder like this canister it
comes in chewables which I like then
it's because it's easy to take a pocket
full of a little Ziploc bag okay but
then it also comes uh in liquid okay so
I-26 is a great great product because it
gives you it says right on the label
gives you 25 of your daily requirements
okay of cholesterol and it's made from
whole eggs it's made from whole eggs and
if you're
even if you're not sexually active but
in your child bearing years
you know you go to a party and you have
a few drinks and you get wooed by uh
some guy and you get pregnant
Okay now what's going on with that baby
what's going on with that that
that
um embryo okay and so it may be too late
when you know gosh I missed a period
Well a month has gone by well a month
the neural tube is already farming is
going to be farming normally it's going
to be farming
um
in such a way that you're going to wind
up with a gay or male or a lesbian
female baby
okay now these can be wonderful people
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with these individuals as individuals
okay but
um lesbian and gay behavior is not
normal
reproductive Behavior okay and so I I
looked it up and sure enough
um the
gay gay Behavior
in lesbian Behavior has been reported in
450 species of animals 450 species of
animal now I said this 25 years ago
that
um
the gender issue was not a choice that
people were driven to go that direction
okay by some
deficiency okay and I said this 25 years
ago and people jumped all over me so I
just kept my mouth shut and now we have
so much hard data published okay that I
can't ignore it anymore and so
um
Alzheimer's disease is very quickly
reversible
um let's see here Ms is very quickly
reversible guillain-brae syndrome is
very quickly reversible Parkinson's
disease is very easy reversible
demolinization is very easily reversible
how do we know this because I've done it
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
times over and over and over okay and if
you just take a drug to relieve symptoms
it doesn't give your body anything it
needs to heal itself and repair itself
and function properly remember
Pharmaceuticals
deal with symptoms
and most people are grateful oh my gosh
I'm so grateful I took this prescription
my doctor gave me it reduced my symptoms
or eliminated my symptoms
well let's just look at something that's
very you know simple and common
everybody understands arthritis and you
take a painkiller and your knee knee
problems go away your hip problems go
away but in two or three more years
suddenly now you need a double knee
replacement or double hip replacement
because you didn't deal with giving the
body what it needed to rebuild the needs
and rebuild the hips he just took a pain
reliever okay and so Ponder on this and
think about this and I want you to again
remember this okay this is one of those
things which is unimpeachable evidence
the whole Sciences occurred and changes
because of this
um originally understood that there was
problems back in nineteen
you can see here 1976 I found the first
non-human case of cystic abrose was a
terrible birth defect that every doctor
knew was a genetic terrible genetic
disease of babies okay and I found the
first non-human case they sent out
microscopic slides of this monkey from
Yorkie's Primary Center and Emory
University in Atlanta Georgia where I
was a pathologist
I sent it out to like five medical
schools I say I think this is
um
City fibrosis what do you think but it
didn't tell us from a monkey I just said
I think this is your brothers what do
you think they all sit back said back in
their letterhead yeah this is a classic
example of roses
and then I told him it was from a monkey
and I think I had found the first
non-human case the city of roses and we
could have um animal models to study oh
they were all excited and then some
months later when I told him it was just
a simple genetic disease when I examined
uh did biopsies or the tissues of all
the other 24 baby monkeys in the colony
there that European Primary Center
Atlanta Georgia they all had cystic
fibrosis okay so I checked the dice and
the behaviors there had changed the eyes
took away the monkey pellets so all the
bottomless minerals in it from the
mother and father because they were
picking on each other and they gave them
vegetables and and fruit and things to
be busy eating as opposed to just
plopping down the pellets
and so all these baby monkeys were born
with
um with um
the cystic abrosis
and they fired me because they said it
wasn't genetic they fired me and that's
when I went back to school and became a
naturopathic physician because I knew
the doctors were missing it very badly
and there had to be somebody in the
patient's Corner okay speaking in boxing
terms I had to be in the corner of the
patient because the medical system was
way off on that one and it turns out
they've been way off there are no
genetically transmitted diseases there
are no genetically occurring birth
defects well how come so many people in
your family have it well guys because
everybody eats the same way okay that's
why okay and this is very simple stuff
so again I urge you to use the I-26 I
have my three eggs twice a day with soft
yolks uh it can be soft boiled soft
poached soft scramble butter however you
want to do it so you're not bored with
it all the time and I put our
our salt on it
okay
our seasoned salt from Australia New
Zealand we also have the Himalayan salt
it kind of comes and goes based based on
the supply but this one is here okay and
then I want to remind everybody
that um
it's one of those things where we have
to be
consciously proactively dealing with the
90 essential nutrients okay we deal with
over 600 different diseases we have 5
000 products that deal with that and you
can prevent so much you can add 25 to 50
Health years your life by doing all this
stuff correctly so I urge you to get the
book epigenetics I urge you to get the
book of Hell's Kitchen which goes into
the history of why we have these
problems when we switch from from wood
and Coalition which we've been using for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years everybody's using the wood ashes
and coal ashes as they supplement in
their food and also as a garden
fertilizers who are getting all these
minerals okay because we're using the
ashes which are 95 98 minerals only two
or three percent carbon when we went to
electricity at three o'clock in the
afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
certainly now we gave up our source of
minerals and remember they're talking
about the lion diet now okay the
carnivore diet
well I spent two years in Africa uh in
in the town province in South Africa the
impalasian facility gamers are working
the White Rhino conservation project and
they have the book runner express to
prove what I'm saying okay and we'd
watch lions kill
Antelope and wildebeest and things like
that and the first thing it would eat
would be the livers where all the trace
minerals are at he would eat the heart
and the lungs they would eat the kidneys
they'd eat the arteries they'd eat the
fat
um they drink the blood and then they
would drag the body of their kill
underneath the shade of a tree and
they'd start working on the meat
so if you're just eating red meat salt
and water you're not getting everything
you need and you're going to wind up
with a lot of problems so don't don't
get involved in the lion diet
the reason why they're getting benefit
okay in their skin and their their bowel
movements and all kind of stuff is
because they're giving up gluten they're
giving up wheat brought around oats when
they're eating the lion Dot and the
carnivore diet okay there's no magic in
just eating red meat salt and water they
don't say anything about
avoid carbonated water they just say
water okay so I guarantee you to make
things interesting a lot of people are
enjoying carbonated water which
neutralizes stomach acid so you cannot
efficiently absorb minerals and the
other so
um 30 days on the the
um Lion Dot and the carnivore diet I
want to have a five-year follow-up on
all these people and see what diseases
they get and when they die and so forth
and let's see if you still want to go to
the lion die in the carnivore diet
okay now with that said I'm going to go
to Rebecca here and send us any anything
you want to add to that or any questions
you want to ask
um yeah Dr Olek I want to just add a
little more about the I-26 so I-26 is a
hyper immune egg formula okay with this
hyper immune egg formula there are six
patents and it contains specific
immunity against 26 pathogens so what
does immunity does is it helps to
prevent the attachment of harmful
bacteria within the digestive system
but it also promotes the growth of the
beneficial bacteria and Flora within the
digestive system so
I recommend it for
anyone that's got really bad digestive
system especially
those that are dealing with constipation
and diarrhea those who
just want to improve their digestive
function
reduce digestive bloating
an inflammatory disease so it's really
beneficial in doing so much within the
digestive system
and Dr Wallach guess what it's gluten
free it's non-GMO contains no
biotic
antibiotics anything like those
that could
weaken the immune system it just builds
it up and it works so perfectly with
your 90 essential nutrients in helping
the body to have that good digestive
tract
that can better absorb the nutrients
so thank you for that information of
course uh I like it says right on the
label boldly I'm right on the label
um offers 25 your daily requirement of
cholesterol and people say what what do
you mean daily requirement for
cholesterol my doctor says it's bad stay
away from it it's like saying stay away
from vitamin A
h
well it's like from stay away from
oxygen doctor yeah there you go
but it does come in a powder uh one
scoop your daily dose you can mix that
in water do not take it within two hours
of eggs okay so raw eggs standard eggs
and then this I-26 powder they both have
their own antibodies and if you take
them too close together they will kind
of cancel out the antibodies and prevent
the best pops possible utilization
of that within the digestive system okay
so just something that I wanted to to
add in there it does again I started to
say it comes in a powder it also comes
in capsules and it comes in chewables
that are in a french vanilla or a banana
cream flavor
so really easy I like the chewables
myself
um
because I eat one and then I want
another one and then I want another one
and I stop at three because that's what
I recommend daily dose or the dosage
recommendation is
so I am glad that um you shouldn't take
the I-26 within what how many hours and
about two hours of having eggs
okay yeah so I had three eggs for
breakfast this morning
um at 6 30 so after the show I can have
three of my chewable I-26 with no
problem
so yeah nice little snack too and I
think it's better than a sweet snack and
if anybody's craving sweets but if
you're on the minerals you should not be
craving anything
so
just saying but I again want to welcome
everybody a lot of people came in while
Dr Wallach was doing his monologue thank
you so much for for sharing that
information Dr Wallach I have a lot of
people that are near and dear to me
that
basically they they didn't know what to
do they didn't know how to act
because of
their religious Faith they were afraid
to come out and share how they really
felt about the opposite sex or same sex
and that should not be the case of
somebody being able or having to fear
because of something that they have no
control over
but now we have information
that can be used before conception
that if you are concerned about whether
or not
um you know any type of gender
preference that your child has it's
something that you can take into your
own hands
and reduce
occurrences if that's something that's
important to you
so I'm glad that you were able to find
that research Dr Wallach I did put a
link to it in the chat so for those of
you who are on with us live
that publication it actually came out in
2008.
2008 wow and there's more research
confirming that Dr Wallach and as you
mentioned you've been saying that it's a
nutritional deficiency for over 20 years
well 2008 was not 20 years ago I mean
that's less than 15 years ago
and it's just proving that you were
right in the beginning and I love that
more and more research is proving the
things that you've been saying for 50
years Dr Wallach 50 years
or more yeah of course one of the things
I would see is when I was in Africa I
was saying all this um gay behavior in
between the male giraffes it could be a
female giraffe standing there and the
boy giraffes are going after the boy
drafts okay and it's very famous the
giraffes have a very high rate of
um gayness let's say okay and then you
know gender issues
then
um you know if you grew up in a farm and
I think you grew up on a farm okay I did
if you have a bull calf and when he goes
through puberty and he's chasing boys
instead of girls what happens he becomes
hamburger
the best steak in the world Dr Wallach
maybe you come steak and hamburger right
because uh you don't be feeding this
little bull calf if he's going after the
boys instead of the girls and so they
would just knock them in the head and
cook him
and uh you know make um uh T-bone steaks
and hamburger and all that kind of stuff
uh and just just remember the lion diet
as is being put forth now of just eating
red meat salt and water is not the way
lions eat in Africa okay they eat the
organ Meats first which has all the
trace minerals which have all the trace
minerals in it okay and also cholesterol
in the liver and the fat and so forth
and
um this is why you don't see
much gayness in lions and tigers and
bears okay it's usually animals that are
herbivorous and uh fats and cholesterol
are very low
uh intake
um unless they're eating the seeds if
they're eating the seeds in the grain
they're going to get some cholesterol if
they're just eating the grass they're
not going to get much cholesterol by
eating grass okay
that's right and Dr Wallach I'm super
excited about something that's going to
be starting next week
I mean it's a lot of work but I'm super
excited about it still and that's a
that's a new program
that we have coming out Monday through
Friday
yeah
what called ask doc daily
so
for those of you who can't get enough of
Dr Wallach we are going to be coming out
with a new show also called askley daily
and in this program we're going to go
more into specific things that are on
the minds of the people around us
and I think I think we should start out
with diet I mean it's the beginning of
the year people are looking at Better
Health
let's look at the different diets
bring out the benefits of each of one
the downfalls of each of one and how
none of them are complete without the 90
essential nutrients
okay that's a plan and of course the the
ask doc daily is not going to replace
as doc live the f stock live is still
going to be on right
yeah I love it that's correct
I get you seven hours a week Dr Wallach
wow
crazy okay somebody took somebody had
mentioned to me that I was hogging you
and I did have to say well I did start
on the pig pack so there we go
but Dr well like we have some hands up
so before we get to those hands I just
want to remind everybody that you are
watching ask doc live if you were
invited by somebody's specific make sure
that you get back to them let them know
that you jumped on the show and that you
were able to gain some information that
you will be able to utilize in your own
life and let them know what that
information is now we're going to be
talking about products like the I-26
that we were just talking about but
as people come on and ask questions that
they have in regards to their own health
or the health of someone that they care
about Dr Wallach is going to be giving
Protocols of products that we have found
to make a difference
I mean they're
our supplement companies left and right
you can take the products it changes the
color of your urine and you feel no
different well we invite you to feel the
difference in the products that we will
be presenting to you today Dr Wallach
was so instrumental in their development
and making sure that only quality
ingredients go into this and his son
Steve is carrying on that Legacy of
folks we are worth
that extra amount of time
to find the products the raw ingredients
that go into the products and make no
compromise
so we are investing I would like to
throw something in there at those moment
if I may go ahead let me throw something
in
um an example we started youngin uh over
30 years ago
um we didn't want to be like everybody
else grinding up Limestone and Clay to
put powder into our pellets to make
supplements okay because everybody when
you look at all the vitamins and
minerals everybody who had a vitamin
mineral supplement had all the same
vitamins and minerals as the next guy
okay there's nothing different so we
spent about six months looking around it
was very obvious that the hunzas or the
life expectancy of 120
versus and it's real because the the the
the
[Music]
what they say the um one that has the
best example is Gene kelman from France
she died in 1990
7 at 122 years 164 days so we know that
people can live that long in modern
times okay so she did that
we wanted to do something different so
when we found the hunzas and we really
studied what it was that they were doing
differently why were there why was there
life expectancy 120 in our life
expectancy in America is supposed to
have the best health care System
worldwide was our life expectancy
um 75. okay didn't make sense but we
came out with our sports drink after six
months of research and our sports drink
has 75 minerals in it
our sports drink rebound has 75 minerals
in it okay Red Bull has one magnesium I
repeat that Red Bull has one magnesium
I think they did that because their hero
Bruce Lee who was considered by every
country in the world to be the the what
the exercise guru the weight loss Guru
he died at 32.
okay he died at 32. he looked great at
25 but he looked very bad at age 31 and
he died at 32.
um because he was not doing everything
right he only took one mineral magnesium
that's the only mineral he supplemented
was was magnesium because he believed he
could get everything else well lions are
eating bones and cartilage and ligaments
and tendons and livers and hearts and
all that kind of stuff
and of course Bruce Lee wasn't eating
all that stuff he was eating spaghetti
for lunch and dinner and so so on he was
getting lots of calories but he wasn't
getting the minerals because he only
supplemented was one so Red Bull has
magnesium we have 75 minerals plants
arrive colloidal minerals very highly
absorbable adjustable and usable and we
have it in three forms we have the
sticks
okay which I use a lot of we have in the
canisters okay which has 36 servings
there there's 36 in a box and in the
canister there's uh um 36 servings and
then we have the 12 ounce cans okay in
the Box Dr Wallach there's 30 individual
satchels
so one for each day
there you go
and then
um in the cans okay rebound
there's it does have carbonation so I
popped two of these before bedtime
um you say every other night or every
night and I'll drink one with breakfast
and I'll drink one with lunch or maybe
within a couple hours after lunch and
these this
um is how I get a lot of my minerals but
I'm still taking the healthy brand and
heart pack twice a day okay I have many
witnesses I do this every day I take a
healthy brain and heart pack of
breakfast I take a telegram hard pack at
dinner time I take my rebound I take
um
I take
I think it's like 80 to 90 different
pills tables and capsules twice a day in
addition to everything else
okay and so I'm 83 going on 84. and most
people think I'm in my 50s early 60s
I can't believe I'm 8384 and when you
look at all these famous people and
famous athletes I mean even Pele just
died at 82.
the most famous modern athletes a soccer
player he had won every award that every
athlete could win he just died a couple
of days ago at 82. Paley died at 82 the
guy I mean I think he took the place of
Bruce Lee when Bruce Lee died I think
Paley was the guy that everybody looked
at okay
and so anyway I'm sorry for interrupting
no worries what was I talking about
we were talking about let's go to the
hands Dr Wally huh
let's go to the hands that are up okay
let's go to the hands that are up all
right Rosemary thank you for being on
with us and for having your camera on go
ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with Dr Wallach
hi uh I am I've been on youngevity I've
been on the 90 for about seven years and
I've been on the ultimate daily classic
and my blood pressure is still high is
there something else I should be doing
okay so you have a high blood pressure
issue how much you weigh
125 125 okay
okay
um are you eating any buckwheat no are
you eating any wheat bread or our oats
no
even gluten-free oats no there are no
such thing as gluten-free oats I'm just
testing it okay all right so
um you may want to be using our ultimate
enzymes
two of those say five to ten minutes for
each meal a couple ounces of water and
make sure it'll help you make sure
you're absorbing these nutrients
okay okay also I would take if you're
not taking it take the ultimate daily
classic tablets get two bottles a month
of them so you can take three at
breakfast three dinner time and they
will support healthy blood pressure
healthy blood flow through Black Drawers
in the brain the heart the kidneys and
every place else including the legs and
so forth
but if you're on medication for the high
blood pressure do not
cold turkey off the medication but as
your blood pressure begins to come down
you can slowly reduce medication based
on the number it usually takes about
anywhere from two to six weeks okay and
so be sure to add that ultimate daily
classic tablet three twice a day and
then again make sure you're staying away
everybody in the household has got to be
gluten-free because you get
cross-contaminated in the laundry the
bed the couches the rugs and we want our
intestines to look like a shag rug we
have to have those Villi which increase
the absorbent Surface by 98 percent
and then when you eat that gluten or
have a gluten issue okay
um those are are
phagopyries out of Buckwheat those Villi
go away instead of looking like a shag
rug your intestines look like a plastic
tube and you cannot efficiently absorb
nutrients so you want to find out what
these other people are eating during the
day you know they're away from the house
maybe they're sneak eating pancakes for
breakfast waffles for breakfast they're
eating hamburger buns they're eating
spaghetti like Bruce Lee did and you're
getting cross-contaminated in the
laundry so that's a possibility so you
want to check all that out okay
you may have to if you have people who
won't get off of the bad stuff you may
want to run an empty load with all the
detergents and everything and clean out
the washer and dryer and clean out the
the filter for the dryer before you put
your stuff in there okay look at those
kind of things it wouldn't hurt to get a
hair analysis you hit the book rare
Earth's been cures chapters 10 11 page 2
72 is where it starts tells you how to
collect the hair how to package it where
to ship it and
we'll find out a lot about your
absorption your digestion we'll find out
what nutrients you're deficient in and
so it wouldn't hurt if you haven't had
in the last year if you haven't had a
hair analysis get that book rare has
been cures chapter 10 11 page 272 let's
get a hair analysis and we can be more
specific okay
okay Rosemary if you want to unmute
yourself there was a little bit of
background noise I just
yeah
oh okay so did you have any other
questions for Dr Welling no that was all
okay thank you all right
thank you so much Rosemary for being on
with us today we love love it whenever
people come on live with their cameras
bringing information
um about their questions because
other people are going to have questions
similar and as we're going through if
you think of anybody that's dealing with
or experiencing any of the conditions
that any of the people coming on and
asking questions with us are
experiencing as well
think about it you may have heard the
solution to something that they have
been dealing with for decades without
any positive results
so make sure that you share this program
with others that's what this is for this
is a resource that can be used around
the world to help make stronger homes
communities and
Nations right Dr White Rick you can get
an A-Plus
awesome well let's go to the next town
that is up Dr Wallach and Ryan if you're
able to come on camera with us and
unmute you are on live with Dr Wallach
good morning uh Doc and Miss Dukes
thanks for having me on can you hear me
yes I apologize is the name Robin
Ryan okay where are you from
Texas Texas
okay how can we help you today
um I have some
um several symptoms and several
questions is that fine
um
you're speaking too softly I can barely
hear you
I I have um several uh symptoms and
questions okay go ahead
I weigh 130 pounds I am five foot six
and 25 years old my symptoms I have I
developed I believe I developed um
naraco cell on the left side three days
ago
um I have slight pain on the right side
both testes feel firmer and I had
um I have non-ashemic priapism
um a week ago and sitting too long
um causes joint jotes of pain to my
inner thighs uh feet and inner knee
those are just symptoms uh for now
and um I was just wondering if my joint
pain and muscle cramps
no
it's just a sending Joseph pain to my
inner thigh and feet and knee if I said
too long
okay okay let me ask you a couple
questions
um
I know you're only 20 you say you're 25
years old do you have any white gray or
silver here and you're much faster here
is that a no no sir I do okay I don't
have okay uh do you have any ringing in
your ears yes
okay how many times a night you wake up
to urinate once three times five times
once
okay
do you have any balance problems or
dizziness or vertigo
occasionally
okay
all right do you have any uh changing
your voice yes
okay so you have voice changes that's
the ninth Trail nerve being squeezed
getting up at night to urinate even just
once so it can be a squeezing of the
spinal cord and the spinal cord is
telling your urinary bladder to urinate
is not a prostate problem
because it happens in women and women
don't have prostate glands
tonight is ringing the ears is a
squeezing of the vestibular branch
um of the
um
eighth cranial nerve okay and I want you
to get the book in CD it's all in your
head
and I'm going to show you something this
is my favorite picture
okay
the top picture is a picture of a human
skull normal
it's a quarter of an inch thick
you look at the bottom and said a
picture of a human skull it's an inch
and a half to two inches thick and
that's how she approaches the skull when
you have osteoporosis of the skull the
the healthy bone is replaced by
connective tissue okay it's replaced by
connective tissue and that connective
tissue squeezes the 12 pairs of cranial
nerve squeezes the spinal cords and you
get 37 different diseases which are
talked about in this book and in this CD
okay so I want you to you know go to
um
and stock live and and uh Rebecca is
going to give out her ability to get
this to you so
um when we're done here Rebecca give out
your you know your
numbers so people can get the CD from
you in the book from you okay and this
is going to help rebuild everything and
all your symptoms can go away this is
not a genetic thing it's not an unimmune
thing your body's not attacking itself
you're just um what do you eat for
breakfast
white rice
um soft boiled eggs
um salmon vegetables
what was the last one vegetables okay
good
um do you ever eat any buckwheat or
pancakes or
um
every um anything like um like more than
a month ago I'm sorry more than a month
ago oh you gave it up more than a month
ago yes sir okay but for 24 years you
were eating gluten or buckwheat or both
yes sir okay good so you did give it up
okay a month ago okay good you're on the
start okay so you should start seeing
benefit here pretty soon wouldn't hurt
for you to get a hair analysis also get
the book rare Earthman cures
um
and again Rebecca will give you a phone
number that you can go to to get a hold
of these things but uh chapter 10 11
page 272 that's going to give you a lot
of information and don't forget to use
and don't just use salt from the grocery
store you want to use our seasoned salt
from Australia New Zealand has a lot of
um the minerals in it from the seaweed
and so eight or nine different seaweeds
we have the Himalayan salt
um we have like I think it's like eight
different sources for the for this um uh
minerals okay for these minerals and
we're the only ones in the world that
put them in our supplements everybody
else just grinds up
um Limestone and clay
and so everybody else's minerals are you
know they get 12 or 15 or 20 or
something like that we're the only ones
where you get 75 okay
there's
75 minerals
there's 75 nutritional minerals in here
in fact I had a call just a couple of
days ago from Theo Ratliff okay the guy
whose picture is on here
a great story he was your age when I
first dealt with him he was 24 years old
he had bone to bone arthritis and Bose
knees he had the cartilage slipped off
his hip he fractured his shooting arm
wrists on his right hand and the
um Atlanta Hawks terminated him and he
lost his 35 million dollar contract he
was you know basketball player and um we
made the healthy Bone and Joint pack for
him we made the rebound for him and he
came back
six months later got his his position
back he played for 11 more years and
made a hundred million dollars because
he was perfect and never had a bad day
for 11 years playing professional
basketball
so and he called me the other day and
just wishing me a happy Holidays and
Merry Christmas everything and he was
very very good guy he took the
percentage of his his
um income
and he bought some
um property okay in Georgia
and Tennessee and built
um
places where kids who were having
problems physically and mentally to go
to and get healed and using the
youngevity products and I thought that
was such a beautiful thing he did for
the community and he continued to do
that okay but he he was 24 years old
when I started him on the products and
made the healthy Bone and Joint pack for
him and and also the rebound for him
okay so
um we can all think
you know if they Theo Ratliff for that
okay well let's hear from you every
couple weeks but um Rebecca give out
your ability to get these um
um books and CDs and hair analysis and
all that kind of stuff to him
Dr Wallach the best place though is drj
wallach.com
that's where you're going to find all of
Dr wallach's
Dr
yeah d r j Wallach
w-a-l-l-a-c-h.com now Dr Wallach he had
mentioned about having some concerns
with the testicles would you recommend
the Zara test for him yeah is there a
test and of course there's three eggs
um twice a day and he can also have the
I-26
um once a day or twice a day whatever it
wants but um also you're exactly right
is there a test he could take three of
those twice today I do that I'm again
um 83 years old I'm
five foot six
weigh 142 pounds and I've never had a
problem with um chasing girls but it's
one of those things where just you know
because it's a great product for males
and people you know guys would ask me
well what do you do here is your age you
know make sure everything's working well
I take three of those zero test twice a
day
and um uh you know it comes you know in
tablets so we have zero Femme for girls
where you know we don't we don't just
apply things only to boys we have a
seraphim for girls three of those twice
a day and it's one of those things where
it makes girls girly and and it makes
boys boys okay
good question all about Solutions right
Dr Wallach yep
awesome well Dr Wallach we got four
minutes before that break would you like
to take one more hand or go on break
let's let's take one more hand before we
go for a break okay let's go to Joe Joe
go ahead and unmute yourself and if
you'd like to come on camera with us
that would be fabulous as well you are
on live with Dr Wallach
oh let's try to unmute you one more time
there you go okay am I here
I hear your voice loud and clear okay
good morning Dr Wallach um I apologize
is your name Jill or Joe um Joe it's
it's Jody I go by Joe that's fine
um so I did the hair analysis test and
um I have a couple questions uh they
recommended some
um minerals some products for me
I am having a trouble with the copper I
was just taking a little bit of it
because it upset my stomach and then I
would eat food and I took it and then I
started vomiting after I took the copper
stop there for a minute
was this a recommendation by the hair
Analysis company
um yes and I was doing youngevity
products but they were making me um also
sick to my stomach and getting very very
sore all over my body so what how much
you weigh how much you weigh
um I weigh 137 I'm 5A and I'm 56 years
old
can you ring in your ears
no how many times you wake up at night
to urinate
oh once three times five times uh maybe
once a week I wake up at night two years
okay so it's not a big deal
okay I apologize you said you're 56. yes
okay
all right and you have a pressure
diabetes
um no actually uh one doctor said that I
was
um pre-diabetic
okay all right well here's what I would
suggest disregard what that hair
Analysis company is saying because they
have the standard supplement program
okay so the first thing you have to do
is get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat bun around oats okay no
wheat butter and oats
and no buckwheats and then I want you
you know eat like an Asian eat rice and
sweet potatoes and white potatoes and
that kind of stuff nothing fried okay
I'm allergic to rice
oh well that's why we have
um let's see here you're allergic to
everything what do you eat
um I can eat eggs and I can eat
um
on apples and some meat not chicken or
turkey I can eat
um some like beef non-fatty kind of beef
um have you tried liver
beef liver ah a calf liver
yes I cannot handle it that also makes
me want to throw it but but I I have it
in pills I mean I can do a pill of it um
okay and so anyway what I want you to do
is make sure that you're getting the the
90. okay so there's several ways to do
it number one you can try have you tried
or rebound
yeah and so I've always been allergic to
bromelain and pineapple and so I can
handle rebound like once or twice a week
in a small amount and then my body
starts getting sore again and the same
with the 90 Essentials
um I had to stop them
um because I started getting achy all
over so I don't know if I have a
detoxification on you we got to do
something yeah I I need to see that uh
hair analysis so next time you come on
um I want you to
um have sent me or texted
um send it to D to Doc at
drjwalik.com Jody if you would
RJ I need to see that here analysis
because yeah it sounds like you're it
sounds like you're allergic to oxygen
and water
well thankfully not that but yeah I have
a lot of stuff
um yeah okay okay so anyway we need to
really look at the details here before I
can make any more recommendations
because you say you tried that you get
bad you tried that you get bad you tried
this you get bad there's something else
going on there okay
um do you live in a household where
there's other people do you have a
spouse do you have kids do you have
brothers and sisters mom and dad
um yes I have a spouse and then our
daughter moved back with us she's also
very sick but okay
um what kind of do you work outside the
home no
okay what kind of work does your husband
do
um Athletics
he's an athletic director okay does he
eat oatmeal for breakfast
no
what does he eat for breakfast
um he does your uh
the shake um the banana cream shake
um
yeah the fit shake and then
um we have gluten-free scones so he does
that sometimes for breakfast
um he takes like the healthy brain heart
pack and the little packets of um yeah
because I make sure he's not fudging and
eating some gluten or buckwheat outside
the house and then you're washing his
clothes with your clothes you're getting
cross-contaminated
okay so make sure that's not happening
and then let's talk again after I see
the hair analysis okay
okay great I actually have it but I
didn't know how to undo my video thing
um so I will just send that to you next
time and the next question I have
um is uh how do you do a hair analysis
test for dogs I called marlin she told
me to contact you via this
you just do the same thing you clip some
hair off of them and just tell them it's
from a dog uh where do I clip the hair
in the back of their neck then I put
their neck also or yeah that's fine
okay
yeah in front of the body is the same as
they're here in the back of the body
same thing oh it doesn't matter okay all
right and
um yep I have one other question
whenever I take calcium I was tasting
the osteoflex um I get constipated very
very badly
and so I didn't know if you had
any ideas do you get a bad reaction from
drinking water
it depends on what water
okay now there's something deeper going
on here and so I need to see the hair
analysis
I mean everything you put in your mouth
you have a reaction to
so there's something else going on here
so I don't know if it's you have
obviously a process of the skull
and uh so if you don't have the book
it's on your head you need to look at it
I have it I read it okay we'll read it
again okay okay because you may have
obviously approached as a skull because
you have so many things going on there
um it's amazing you're still alive okay
so let's uh get that here analysis to us
and we will um get back to you make sure
we have your phone number and all that
kind of stuff okay okay thank you God
bless
um you too thank you Jody thank you
all right well Dr Wallach let's go ahead
and take a break everybody you are
watching ass doc live
and this program again is being brought
to you by askdoglive.com we do have a
link to many of Dr wallach's books on
our website you can go there some of our
Kindle or some of his books are in
Kindle and available through the website
but then there's also if you don't find
it there go to drj wallach.com and you
will find all of Dr wallach's
Publications and we're getting ready to
come out with a brand new website
hopefully after the first of the year
and it's going to have even more of what
Dr Wallach offers in bundles even to
help you save money so I'm excited about
that and for those of you who love
sharing Dr wallach's book
we're also coming out with an affiliate
program so in a digital world and in a
world where
well even just in a world where you're
sharing about a product that you love
if you're buying it from the corner
store they're not giving you anything to
share your testimony or to help promote
that product
but in our world we think people deserve
to be thanked for sharing information
that can help others so we're coming out
with an affiliate program at Wellness
Publications that will allow you to be
able to have your very own link that you
can share with others and then whenever
they purchase from your link you will
get a thank you check from Wellness
Publications just one thing that Dr
Milan has
agreed to put together
to to help get the information out so
look forward to that
um that's going to be drj wallick.com
and
you are watching askdoc live sponsored
by askdoglive.com and the good people at
zvs radio network we will be right back
after this break
all right and we are back on a stock
live my name is Becca Dukes I am the
host of this program and it is great
honor that I'm able to host this two
hours with you and with the amazing Dr
Joel Wallach so Dr Wallach is here with
us
what are you wanting me to do Dr Wallace
well I want to make a correction in your
speech he said you're the host no you're
the host Tess
yes okay yes I am the hostess of this
program thank you very much Dr Wally for
correcting me on that
um and
Dr well like
he's been doing this for how long
to what how long have you been looking
at nutrition and its effect on the body
since I was nine years old
so
nine years old yeah see I had Tourette
Syndrome very badly
um 20 doctors couldn't heal me 20
doctors in five years could not do
anything positive for me they're going
to put me in an institution and study me
because I had really severe Tourette's
Syndrome I I would take on you know 30
year old men and beat him up I was only
nine years old because I'm throwing 50
pound bales of hay and stuff like that
very strong
but I was really a a wreck and um so it
was a Friday night my parents were
packing my clothes to put me in this in
this um
facility on Monday
and I'm sitting at the end of the bed
saying why am I having all these
problems
why isn't anybody else have the problems
and I'm saying you know
hey it's got to be something I'm doing
wrong it must be me because nobody else
has the problems
and so um the next morning Saturday
morning
because I'm going to this facility on
Monday I go to the barn and I throw my
cereal out I've been eating oatmeal for
breakfast forever so I've turned my
cereal out to the chickens and my
Wheaties out to the chickens and I just
got a kind of like a small bucket maybe
a couple of quart bucket full of the
Alfalfa pellets that we gave the calves
it had all these vitamins and minerals
in it and so I put that in my cereal but
we'll put milk on it and I had them I
had the Alfalfa pellets with all these
vitamins and minerals in there I had
like 30 different vitamins and minerals
in those pellets
and uh headed for breakfast on Saturday
morning headed for breakfast on Sunday
morning had breakfast for Monday morning
at three o'clock on Monday afternoon I'm
cured
after five years and 20 doctors and tens
of thousands of dollars my parents spent
trying to get me healed guess what I
cured myself
in in three days or two and a half days
just by taking bottoms and minerals and
so I knew when I was nine years old the
doctors didn't know what they were doing
because how could a nine-year-old figure
this out
and these all these doctors these 20
famous doctors
in Central Missouri and St Louis and
Illinois and everything pediatricians
psychiatrists they couldn't figure it
out okay they're just giving me drugs
and so
that's when I started studying nutrition
and health I didn't say anything and
after
a just a couple of weeks at church
people are whispering and pointing at me
because it was a very obviously very
very different
and people would come up to well I have
this problem Oh what do I do about this
I'm only nine years old only nine years
old what do I you know they're freaking
me out because we want me to solve their
problems when I was nine so that's how I
started studying nutrition
and health
that just goes to prove how simple
it is yeah even a nine-year-old could
figure it out
it takes a little bit of discipline but
folks when you feel the difference
you don't want to go back
and I had been dealing with pain Dr
Wallach since I was eight
but it took until I was 43
before I heard your message
and stopped following what the doctors
had been telling me to do
for
35 years okay now have any of those
doctors were giving that misinformation
or have any of those passed away and
died
I have no clue I didn't follow up with
them
[Laughter]
that makes me a bad coach because here I
have a solution and I didn't follow up
with the people that were giving me the
wrong information but
no I'm not a bad coach because I'm taken
today and the information I have now and
spreading it far and wide as much
you are one of God's angels I'll be a
testimony to that well thank you Dr
Wallach I appreciate that I accept and
receive and
oh we have so many people
um Dr Wallach that are waking up and
wanting to know what they can do to help
themselves so
there was a question in the comments
here
and Theresa wants Teresa wants to know
what can I do for thinning
loss of hair
so
there's a lot of different things that
can play into somebody losing hair
female or male
so if we were going to recommend just
the standard making sure you get all
that you need with a symptom of hair
loss we don't know if there's a thyroid
issue
or digestive issues
what would you recommend Dr Wallach okay
well the first thing we want to do is
get rid of the bad stuff to maximize
absorption no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat nobody
around oats no sugar no carbon or drinks
you all got to go even the diet one's
got to go
and then we don't have a weight on her
and so let's go by 100 pounds of body
weight I wanted to have one healthy
brain and heart pack per month one
Health it has 215 nutrients in it until
the brain and heart attack but it still
has the core in there the 90 the healthy
shark packs the core okay I want her to
have one healthy brain and heart pack
for 100 pounds of body weight she weighs
140 150 pounds I'd never go with two
healthy Brandon hard packs a full dose
of breakfast dinner if she weighs 110
120 130 I never take one healthy brand
hard packed
um per month and take a half of those
during the breakfast half a dose of
everything at dinner time and then I
want her also
they have the MSM she can take again per
100 pounds of body weight one bottle of
MSM so if she only weighs 110 120 pounds
or less uh would be um uh one bottle a
month so you could take three twice a
day that's going to help her support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
which includes
the skin okay the skin is two-thirds
connective tissue and the hair follicles
you know require a happy relationship
with the skin okay and then I also want
her to have the
um Hair Skin and Nails in order to have
three of those twice a day it's two
bottles a month
and let's see here I also
um want her to have the collagen
peptides take a school without their
morning drinks whether evening drink
that's going to take two of the standard
size canisters of our collagen peptides
a scuba that breakfast give it at dinner
time and don't forget the Hair Skin and
Nails take through those twice a day I
do that that's part of my regimen even
though I take all this other stuff I
still take my hair skin and Nails three
twice a day it's a small bottle
and um Dr Wallach she added in here that
she has no thyroid so what would you add
for that oh she has okay she they took
her thyroid gland out okay sounds like
it's possible that it was removed and
she is 194 so we're gonna increase 94
pounds increase the recommendations that
were just made yeah just double
everything oh no thyroid issues thank
you Teresa big difference yeah that's
what I thought I heard you know it's not
right issues
Okay so
all right yeah if there was a thyroid
issues obviously she could take our
oceans gold take three of those swines
today or she could take the
um let's see here uh the
um um oh
G radical is he radical she could take a
z radical I know that's one of your
favorites Says Z radical she could take
a uh an ounce twice a day if she weighs
194 pounds announced twice a day of Z
radical be two parts a month or the few
coins Z is a pill form I take because I
travel so much I take the Fuqua Z
capsules and the ocean's gold for my
thyroid okay
all right sounds good Dr Wallach and
let's go to the next hand that is up and
Gaila you are on live with Dr wallet go
ahead and unmute yourself
okay I'm unmuted you are unmuted if
you'd like to come on camera you're more
than welcome to
um I'm not sure if I can do that because
I just can't find the app but I don't
want to waste time I can't find where I
was sorry
Kyla okay
yes sir um okay
um my question is I'm unboxed uh covered
and flu vaccine for years I'm engaged to
a man that got the two covered access
and he has a 5G phone and I've read a
lot about issues
uh once we get married and we have
sexual intercourse that is that going to
affect my health because he's had the
vaccine
no
okay
what about the 5G issue is that
something real that you believe in as
far as the okay how much you weigh how
much you weigh I weigh 135.
okay do you have any absolute issues
like high blood pressure diabetes
pre-diabetes anything like that no I
have nothing okay so you're basically
healthy you're just yes I'm 67 I'm a
very young 67 year old okay all right
and you don't have any rain in the ears
or dizziness or waking up five times a
night that would urinate anything like
that no uh yeah I wake up sometimes to
urinate a couple of times maybe maybe
two three times a night maybe probably
two at the max usually
but it's not every night some nights I
sleep all the way through but it's
unusual to sleep all the way through so
maybe one time one or two times a night
okay
so it's not unusual to urinate twice a
night
uh no it's not unusual yeah okay so yeah
you may have the beginnings of
osteoporosis as a skull where your skull
and squeezing the spinal cord spinal
cords telling urinary bladder to urinate
this you don't have a prostate gland so
it can't be a prostate issue right right
right
I've never met a woman that had a
prostate gland okay right
it's an anatomical impossibility okay
right all right so I do want you if you
don't have it to get the book and the CD
it's all in your head and uh it's going
to have the the
um recipe that I'm going to give you
here okay okay the recipe is of course
get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
food process Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat nobody notes no buckwheat
uh no sugar
um let's see here absolutely no peanuts
I want you to also stay away from
um let's see here
um carbonated drinks if you're gonna
drink ooh I drink those all the time I
from the health food store but I drink
them a lot for the cafe carve any drinks
um two or three a day it's Zevia it's
sweet and with stevia but it's
carbonated okay you got to get rid of
the carbonator drinks that's going to be
a big big problem okay
okay because it neutralizes stomach acid
which is required to absorb minerals and
digest food
okay okay so you cannot have carbonate
drinks our rebound or sports drink has
100 nutrients in it 75 minerals and 25
vitamins amino acids uh Red Bull has one
mineral magnesium that's why Bruce Lee
died he only supplemented with magnesium
he supplement with the other
59 essential minerals okay he died
32 he was the fitness Guru in every
country in the world when he was 25 and
then he died at 32 because he did
everything wrong okay who was that Bruce
Lee did you say Bruce Lee yeah oh okay
because the guy with this ministry he
loves Bruce Lee that's his mentor yeah
yeah the Kung Fu guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
and he was he was everybody's hero he
was my hero but then I learned that he
had gluten for breakfast lunch and
dinner and snacks and um he was only
supplementing with magnesium even his B
vitamins he got from breweries he didn't
take B vitamin supplements he's just
stayed breweries and assumed it was
going to have b vitamins in it okay
what's the name of the supplement again
or can I I don't want to take up your
time on the call okay so here we go last
time right now all right 135 pounds
you're right at that Coast
um but um especially since you're
planning on getting married and you may
want to have kids and all this kind of
stuff no I'm 67 I don't think I'm gonna
have kids
well if you're still cycling you could
oh no I'm not not since 2005. okay so
let's go 135 pounds you're right at that
cusp if you have some issues I'd go with
two healthy Brandon hard packs for a
month a photo showing twice a day if you
don't have issues I start out with one
hell to be in hard pack a day take a
half a dose of everything twice a day
and then I want you to get um uh one
bottle of MSM so you can take three at
breakfast three at dinner time and
they're going to support and promote
means repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes bone of self and
skin okay I also want you to get to
collagen peptides take a scoop of that
with your morning drinks with that with
your evening drink uh that'll uh okay
um then I want you to take the Beyond
Osteo effects take a scoop of that with
your morning drinks with your evening
drink if you're taking the healthy brain
and heart pack you'll be getting the
Beyond Osteo effect as part of it okay
and then I also once you get vitamin D3
take three of those twice a day and if
you're a pre-diabetic I want you to take
our sweeties take three of those twice a
day they will support healthy
um blood sugar metabolism do you ever
get sleepy or tired and not within an
hour after eating a big dinner
sometimes yeah yeah I may have some
pre-diabetes you have um uh some
reactive hypoglyce see me after a big
meal especially if you have
carbohydrates in that meal you'll
you know produce too much um insulin and
knock your blood sugar down so you want
that sweetie so you can take three at
breakfast or dinner time it'll be two
bottles a month of the sweeties
and then any blood pressure issues no
okay good all right then don't forget
our rebound
um you know somebody your weight you
could go through two cans a day or two
sticks a day you know they come like
this there's 30 of these sticks in a
bottle or a box used to be in a box and
um they have the 75 minerals and 25
vitamins amino acids in there no
carbonation
then we have the
um
let's see here also oh we have the the
rebound and the
um canister here it has 36 servings in
it
and then of course we have 12 ounce cans
but there is uh carbonation so I like to
pop the tops in two of them before
bedtime put in the refrigerator so they
off gas the carbonation at night they're
flat in the morning all the bubbly's
gone so I have one with breakfast and
um one with lunch or maybe uh half of
lunch or a whole one with lunch or with
an hour after lunch
and it has a hundred nutrients in it Red
Bull has one mineral
magnesium and I guarantee they did that
because Bruce Lee only had one mineral
magnesium and they bet on the wrong
horse because he died at 32. okay right
right
okay so get back to us every couple of
weeks we'd like to hear what's going on
and uh thank you so much Kyla thank you
so much I'm I'm a nurse I'm an RM but
I'm I couldn't write that fast so can I
get with somebody so I'm not taking up
your time to get this all down
okay with two things number one it's in
the book it's on your head and the CD
that's also in the book epigenetics
okay
but
um this is recorded
oh okay and so you can come back and so
um Rebecca will tell you how to call
back and get the information and listen
to it a hundred times okay okay thank
you so much doctor Take Care thank you
for your good work helping people
accomplish you thank you you too
and you can also go to ask stock live if
you were invited by somebody specific or
you
um have a youngevity distributor that
you're working with make sure that you
get back with them for the best ordering
options but on our website we have a
contact us you could submit your
question there remind us of who you are
and what you're experiencing and we can
get that protocol to you as well thank
you so much you're very welcome Dr
Wallach let's go to the next hand up and
I think it's Ryan Ryan did you have
another question
go ahead and unmute yourself
sorry doc um I I have another question
um
if I were to take um did photos twice a
day of um the healthy brainer heart pack
I would be getting um I think 800
micrograms of selenium I'm just afraid
of um Highway 142 and I've been doing
that for
75 years
okay
um there's the second question
um
should I supplement an extra magnesium
to achieve the two to one ratio of
calcium to magnesium because Osteo FX
has um what I would do
um is use the rebound
because it has a like I say 75 minerals
including the magnesium
you don't want to just pick on one
nutrient that's that's
um which I say that is the sick
mentality of the medical system where
they pick it you need
you need 90 essential nutrients you need
60 minerals and they just say oh oh you
need some zinc
what a stupid thing to say
okay you need all 90 essential nutrients
and if you don't know what you've been
taking or if how much you're absorbing
get it get the hair analysis get the
book
okay I'll get the book uh rare Earth's
been cures go to chapter 10 11 go to
page 272 it tells you how to collect the
hair uh how to package where to ship it
don't forget to put the check in there
or the money order because the lab won't
run the test without the money and
you're going to get specific information
about individual nutrients and um I I
rarely rarely rarely rarely rarely tell
people to take one specific nutrient
because usually they have a relationship
with several other nutrients and it can
take a lot of one it makes the others
deficient and that sort of thing and so
you really have to pay attention to a
little bit more detail and just well my
doctor said take some zinc
um Bruce Lee said take magnesium
okay it's that's why he died at 32
because he's way offbeat on those things
of course uh he didn't he didn't have
any
uh official training
in nutrition but he did a lot of reading
of you know books were on the market
um from
people who were you know self-anoided
nutritionists and and
dietitians and stuff like that and so he
would read all these books and he came
up with all these schemes based on other
people's
concoctions okay which is an incorrect
thing to do and it cost him his life he
died at 32. now just before he died his
last three months he knew he had made a
horrible mistake and he went from having
the diet that he'd had for 20 something
years he just ate fruit and vegetables
for three months and then he just died
suddenly
32 49 years ago
okay
yes yes sir
all right thank you Ryan
sorry thank you was there another
question
um yes ma'am um is
okay is the varicocele are permanent or
can it be um
I I'm not hearing what he's saying is
the varicocele uh permanent
well the varicel the testicles no
that goes away very quickly because it
all has to do is connective tissue and
elastic tissue and that kind of stuff
don't forget the
um is there a test take three of those
twice a day this can give you more
testosterone don't forget the three eggs
joints today to give you the cholesterol
so you can make the testosterone
okay
and yeah these things are self-healing
if you give the body all the raw
materials just like you fracture your
leg
do you have to do much no you just give
your body all the nutrients it needs and
it repairs a fracture you don't need to
have the doctor anesthetize you put a
pin in your bone and all this kind of
stuff that's how that's why there's so
many doctors who are orthopedic surgeons
okay and again for
arthritis
we spent each year in America just to
treat the symptoms of arthritis just to
treat the symptoms of arthritis in
America we spend
626.8 billion dollars just to treat
osteoporosis in America we spend 2.3
trillion dollars so between the two we
spend three trillion dollars a year just
to treat the symptoms of arthritis
osteoporosis because doctors are telling
people oh just take more calcium
what about the other 59 nutrients that
are necessary for the calcium to work
what about getting off the gluten so you
can absorb the calcium okay they just
give you little pieces and that's
because they're making so much money
three trillion dollars a year just to
treat the symptoms of arthritis and
osteoporosis you got to be kidding me
in any other industry huh that's a lot
of money Dr Wallach
well is there statistics
yeah
well let's go to the next town that is
up Dr Wallach and CJ go ahead and oops
CJ go ahead and unmute yourself
hello CJ CJ are you able to unmute
yourself I just sent you a request there
you go you're online good morning good
morning ducks thank you so much for
taking my call here's my big question
and I hope doc can help me
um yesterday I was a health uh nurse
practitioner wanted to
um purchase the the healthy brain and
heart pack but she said to me that the
Osteo the Beyond Osteo does not have any
K2 and she needs the in order for the
calcium to be absorbed in the body open
up the cells it needs the K2 so she says
that means the calcium is not going to
be properly absorbed doc can you shed
some light on that for me please have
you ever heard of the science of crapola
yes doc you have said it so many times
but I I need to respond to her properly
okay well you've respond to her properly
by saying look
um vitamin D3 take extra vitamin D3
um it's you take um our healthy brain
and heart pack Vitamin K is in there
it's in there yes and she also mentioned
dogs that her I guess one of the thing
is that her the last report or something
she did her the levels in or the calcium
in her blood was very high and so she
wasn't sure if you need your analysis
get a hair analysis because the odds are
if her calcium levels in her her
um blood is high that means her
parathyroid glands are pulling calcium
out of the bones because she's not
absorbing calcium she's probably eating
oatmeal for breakfast eating buckwheat
for lunch and dinner and you know what
can I say thank you
well I want to see her hair analysis
let's see how perfect she is
okay
okay doc thank you so much yeah a
medical doctor
um is the last person
that I'm gonna that I would listen to
when it comes down to nutritional
information unless they have a PhD in
nutrition even then I'd be skeptical
okay thank you so much doc
all right Dr Wallach let's just move
right into the next town that is up and
Mona go ahead and unmute yourself if
you're able to come on camera with us
that would be fantastic as well I just
sent you a request to unmute
Mona are you there
oh all right well Dr balik while Mona is
she made Mona may have been a doctor and
went someplace else well oh there she is
she's unmuted Mona go ahead you're on
live with Dr Wallach
uh good morning can you all hear me yes
yes
oh great great so I am a newcomer to you
Miss Dr Wallace I have only heard of you
once on the radio no so this so this is
all new information for me but I've been
having
some ongoing health issues and um so I
just want to kind of talk with you about
things that I should do I've been
um I go to a regular Western doctor but
I also go to naturopathic medicine
doctors as well
so what are your issues one of the
things I've really been struggling with
is
um pain under my right rib cage and in
my stomach area and also my acid reflux
has been very severe lately
okay and I'm I'm 64 years old I'm 5'4
and about 123 pounds okay
um do you have any pre-diabetes or
diabetes
no do you have any high blood pressure
anyone high blood pressure no actually
my blood pressure it was high earlier
this year but it's back down to normal
and I've had numerous blood tests
um I have I have severe migraines as
well and I had an MRI on my brain
because they thought maybe I had a
little mini stroke that all came back
clear everything's been coming back good
okay uh how many times you wake up at
night to urinate once three times five
times
um I don't wake up every night but once
in a while if I do it's about once
usually it's because I've drank a lot of
water in the evening time
okay do you have any rain in the ears
any tinnitus or ringing in the ears
hello
I do I do have ringing in the ears and I
have some ongoing dizziness which they
have been kind of talking about
vestibular migraines okay so you have
dizziness this is called uh vertigo
okay has your voice changed has your
voice changed no okay
um let's see here
um
do you have any did you ever have Bell's
Palsy or one side of your face troops no
okay
um
did you ever have it like did you ever
get headaches
oh I do regularly and many times it's
and they do talk about the tension in my
neck the muscles I'm going to a physical
therapist to kind of stretch my neck and
sort of deal with that
okay stop
okay what I want you to understand is
the odds are you have the either the
beginnings of or you have
um something called osteoporosis of the
skull oh yeah book and CD
uh-huh on your head
and again I'll remind you the difference
between a normal skull at the top where
it's a quarter of an inch thick and an
osteoporosis skull on the bottom which
is an inch and a half to two inches
thick okay and squeezing the nerves the
fifth cranial nerve trigel neuralgia did
they ever say it might have trigenital
neuralgia with all that headaches
no okay never heard of that I've never
heard of that one okay and then uh let's
see here
um what about the stomach acid reflux
issue yeah I was getting to that did you
ever do you ever have an irregular
heartbeat
I do you know it's interesting because
once in a while I feel like I'm really
revved up I feel like I'm like whoo okay
like I'm on should you get a faster did
you ever get diagnosed with um atrial
fibrillation where you have a fast
irregular heartbeat no I haven't because
it doesn't happen very often and it's
very quick and passing okay I've had
EKGs and all of that done and that's all
always come back normal yeah well when
you have afib you have a fast heart rate
irregular heart rate and you can get
what's called
um
I see here uh you get a stomach issue
okay oh gastroparesis which is terrible
pain in the stomach and doctors think
you have an ulcer and they'll take all
kinds of pictures and make yourself yeah
and take it and they probably want they
probably want to do that next have me
swallow something yep and um basically
this is all due to obviously approaches
skull squeezing the tens cranial nerve
the vagus nerve and um and they'll make
a couple of thousand dollars off you and
not find anything because it's all in
your head that's why you want to get
that book and the CD it's all in your
head okay
www.drjwalek.com www.drjwalk.com
and the products you'll you'll pay
wholesale prices for the products if you
get on auto ship I will pay the shipping
for you okay if you're not a ship
okay and so yeah it sounds like you can
ask you a process of the skull and
you're starting to get all these things
happening and it doesn't just happen
like switch on switch off it's a
graduate there's 37 different diseases
you can get from osteoporosis to the
skull and one of the more common ones is
you get terrible pain in the stomach
that'll bring you to your knees it's
called gastroparesis but doctors once
you believe you have an ulcer need all
these diagnostic things going on the
recommended pry list back for me I'm
sorry they recommended Prilosec of
course for me
you know for the acid mm-hmm
yeah and so yeah they're going the wrong
direction okay it's all in your head
okay
so okay let's go there and how much do
you weigh
I weigh about 123. 123. okay
123. okay yeah okay yeah yeah I got it
here okay 123. and so I do want you to
I take um let's see 123 right at that
cost that starts out with one get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
Wheaton about rhinos no sugar no carbon
or drinks you know the diet yeah that'll
be that'll be a switch for me that's for
sure okay
and you're talking no and then Dr
Wallach you're talking no oils like
olive oil or anything like that yeah no
olive oil okay
yeah olive oil has killed more people in
all the wars and world's history
wow
okay and so none of that and then
um you need to take 123 pounds you write
that code so let's go with one healthy
brain and heart pack per month the half
of those are having a breakfast half a
dose of everything dinner time one
bottle a month of the MSM should take
three at breakfast three dinner time
that's going to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes a bone itself
and then
I also want you to take the vitamin D3
through those twice a day okay uh that's
two bottles a month vitamin D3 I also
want to get our ultimate daily classic
Talent let's get three two bottles of
those a month so you can take three at
breakfast three at dinner time
okay that's going to support and promote
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain the heart to
kidneys uh your legs every place else
and um uh it's it's a miracle thing with
blood flow and blood pressure and all
that kind of stuff and if you do have
some
um let's see here if you have reactive
hypoglycemia in other words if you get
dizzy or sleepy an hour or so after
eating a big dinner do you ever get
dizzy after eating it
um not really probably just if I ate too
much
so if you eat too much sometimes you get
sleepy after dinner yeah yeah yeah you
mean in the beginnings yeah you may hear
the beginnings of pre-diabetes or a
reactive hypoglycemia so yeah continues
you want to take three of our sweeties
at breakfast and three dinner time
they'll eliminate that because you're
getting early warning signals here
okay that's why you check your oil when
you go to the right the gas station
that's why you check the air in your
tires when you go to the gas station you
don't wait until you have a flat you
don't wait until your engine burns up
you you do the testing and so when you
see these little signals don't wait
until the doctor says well the only
thing that's going to help you is an
ablation we need to anesthetize you take
your heart out of your chest and touch
it all over a hot Branding Iron to stop
the the area in your heart that's making
your heart beat funny it's not a heart
issue it's just all squeezing the tens
cranial nerve which controls the right
Rhythm of the heart
okay okay okay
well thank you yeah this will be this
will be a definite change for me I love
oatmeal so well that's where you're
having that's why you're having your
problems if you love oatmeal that's your
worst enemy
yeah
okay
rice that's why the Asians live longer
than anybody else because
most of them now not everybody because
there's places in China where they eat a
lot of Wheat and they have a lot of
illnesses the rest of China don't have
okay yeah yeah and so when you look at
the the pure Asians who live on sweet
potatoes and rice and seaweed and fish
and that kind of stuff their average
lifespan is their life expectancy is
84.7 ours is 74
.7 okay they live 10 years longer than
us
yeah yeah and this should take care of
sort of that dull pain that's under my
rib cage which they looked at my
gallbladder and said that was fine
um yeah it could be but you might want
to just take our ultimate enzymes we
call it the gallbladder in a bottle
um yeah you take one or two of those say
10 minutes before a meal with a couple
ounces of water uh could be that it
could be your intestines since you're
eating so much oatmeal it could be your
intestines
um your ascending a colon
making that 90 degree right turn there
this is where you really get a lot of
damage to your colon and your small
intestines from all that wheat you've
been eating for
um 64 years
right
yeah okay that oatmeal will kill you
okay well thank you for that information
okay a couple of weeks people want to
know whatever happened to that Mona girl
that's right the Newbie here on the
Block
well Mona welcome welcome I'm glad you
found us
and just a little bit of encouragement
um I suffered from migraines for 35
years
it's one of the first things that went
away when I got on the supplement
program and Christy who's on with us she
put in the comments
um regarding migraines when I gave up
sugar
amazingly enough the migraines never
reappeared the bad foods cause a lot of
problems
and they absolutely yeah okay thank you
you're welcome so get back with the
person that invited you to this program
and let them know that you were able to
get on thank them for it the Replay for
this program will be up next Thursday at
askdoclive.com so
um our digital Master our webmaster is
on a very much a deserved vacation so
he'll be back um next Thursday and have
it available then but you can also go to
um
YouTube look up critical Health news and
I'm going to try to get it up sooner
there
so
Dr Wallach I think Gala has another
orgyler has another question so guy like
go ahead I know you put the question in
the comments go ahead and ask it
are you able to unmute yourself
um so her question is you had asked her
there you we hear you
okay thank you Dr Wallach this is Kyla
Taylor again and I was asking you about
um my symptoms and you said osteoporosis
but you asked me about ringing to the
ears which I do not have but I am having
some hard of hearing issues some hearing
difficulties yeah and of course this is
the auditory branch of the atrial under
being squeezed it goes along with
osteoporosis of the skull and uh ear
nose and throat doctors love
osteoporosis of the skull your voice
changes you have trouble swallowing you
lose your sense of taste
um
now you lose your sense of smell because
your olfactory nerve which is cranial
nerve number one is getting squeezed and
then you get ringing in your ears you go
to the ear doctor and they give you
hearing aids ear nose and throat doctors
love osteoporosis of the skull you are
their meat
okay
okay that'll all goes away okay thank
you
all right thank you so much for that
follow-up and another question that a
lot of people are experiencing Dr
Wallach you get that inflammation going
in there it's squeezing on those nerves
yep because it's not got the
nutrition that it needs to be able to
keep everything in its place when it
comes to the disc the vertebrae all of
that connective tissue filling in
because it thinks it needs to help
strengthen because of the depletion
that's going on in all those tunnels
there's 12 pairs of cranial there's 12
come on the left side 12 come on the
right side the spinal cord comes down to
the back of the skull and those tunnels
that those nerves in the spinal cord go
through when you have as you approach to
the skull they fill up so you're down to
like 20 or less of the original
uh normal space
putting tremendous pressure on those
nerves in the spinal cord and that's why
all these diseases appear 37 we've
counted they're in the book in the CD
it's all in your head and then of course
there's another set the truth about
nutrition it's a book in CD and DVD goes
along with that you know if you want to
dig deeper
um this we we've spent an enormous
amount of time money and energy digging
this all up remember
um
I I have six years of nutritional
training at University agricultural
School University of Missouri I'm a
veterinarian I have a 10-year study
based with Marlon Perkins at Washington
University in St Louis and and uh to
Burns Hospital in St Louis
um and see here is we're looking at
twenty thousand autopsies
um on 457 different species of animals
and humans okay over a 10-year period
and it's in the Smithsonian Institute as
a National Treasure
okay I'm very very proud of that
because we proved that there were no
gently transmitted diseases or no
autoimmune diseases
and the original thesis the book the
disease of exotic animals still sells
for 25 000 each new in the package never
opened you can get them used beat up
on Siri and Siri okay are there any of
those books or the disease of exotic
animals available for sale and if
they're pretty beat up you might get
them for two thousand dollar or three
thousand five thousand dollars
um then if they're in pretty good shape
eight thousand dollars and if they're
still in in the um plastic wrapper and
never opened they're 25 000 bucks so and
that's why we came out with the book
um
in the book here uh epigenetics and we
started the new science of epigenetics
to replace this the science of genetics
now the genes are good for your eye
color your gender and all that kind of
stuff but there are no gently
transmitted diseases well how come I
have five generations of people in my
family was arthritis well that's because
they're all ate the same way and all
lived in the same county
nutritional minerals do not occur in
uniform blank around the crust of the
earth when we switch to
electricity from coal everybody's access
to nutritional minerals went away do you
want to send a document 264 came out in
1936 and said there's no longer
sufficient minerals in our farmlands in
America to support healthy longevity in
humans I mean this is blatant this is
not something I'm making up this is
something everybody recognizes and so
but I'm the only one openly preaching it
everybody else is keeping their mouth
shut so you can keep coming in asking
for hearing aids
uh Dr Wallach I um had the honor of
meeting with one of our coaches who
actually is a practitioner yesterday
um and she goes around and travels with
the team and we were having gluten-free
pizza we my son and I we have this
little kind of tradition to try to find
the best gluten-free pizza in town and
she joined us her and her husband and as
we were talking
it was she's been in youngevity about
the same amount of time and that second
year of her being in all she wanted for
Christmas was the book
the book
yeah nine one she can afford
well she found one Unfortunately they
were in a position where they could
afford it she said it was
has been the best nine thousand dollar
investment because she's three quarters
of the way through the book
and she has gained so much information
that she
has been able to utilize in her practice
and even with the seven other
certifications and the training that she
has had
yeah thank you for that feedback and
it's it's one of those things that study
was the first one of its kind ever done
okay it was the first one it was kind of
redundant
the first handout on it from National
Institutes and health was like seven and
a half million dollars but before the 10
years was up it was 20 million dollars
and um
the WB Saunders the big publishing
company that published medical textbooks
bought the rights to it
and they published it and sold 90 000
copies at twenty five thousand dollars
each
okay of course I got a little royalty
off of that not much but a little
royalty and so it's one of those things
where as you know it changed science
that study changed science because
everybody thought oh just eat well I get
everything you need no not even close
because plants only need three minerals
and all mammals including human beings
require 60. and the plant can be looked
like the most beautiful carrot the most
beautiful onion the most beautiful beet
most beautiful cucumber the most
beautiful corn the most beautiful
everything and it only has three
minerals in it because nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
they occur in veins like gold and silver
yeah like gold and silver
gold and silver and chocolate Ripple ice
cream doctor
not that I indulge but I know somebody
on this call that does so
um Dr well like I have a question and so
one of our
um associates oh and one thing I wanted
to mention in regards to the
practitioner that I met with last night
she went through the health coach
certification course
she says
she is a certified holistic health coach
and she said she has been able to use
what she learned from that certified
holistic health coach course
and it has just compounded the positive
results that she's getting in all of her
patients who who give it a shot give it
a try she said some of them all they do
is to plant dry minerals
nothing else but they still get positive
results those that can do the whole 90
essential nutrients their results are
even greater
so folks if you're
in the medical field
you got into this field because you
really wanted to help people
well let's take what you learned in
medical school
combine it with nutrition
and you are going to find that your
patients
they may not be coming back to you as
often because they don't have the
diseases but they're going to continue
to provide that income stream because
you are giving them the 90 essential
nutrients that the body actually needs
is deficient of
we are not chemical deficient
our bodies were not designed from
Pharmaceuticals so why not give it the
raw ingredients the body actually was
designed from and with and keep it
strong that way
yeah
very well said and just remember in the
Garden of Eden there was no wheat
brother our oats there's all herbs and
fruit trees
think about that
oats in the Garden of Eden
that's right so Dr Wallach um one
another one of our uh individuals who
sort of vitalistic health coach she's a
youngevity representative just
absolutely loves youngevity will not go
without youngevity because when he does
his acid reflux comes back and he starts
to ache all over
but he had a patient come in
um the gentleman is 30 years old
he's five foot nine
145 pounds
and he and his brother
both same size
um within two two years of each other
have cystic fibrosis
now I know that I am talking to the
expert
on finding
and preventing and
can I use that c word I'm curious you
can use it
cystic fibrosis yes you even sued the
FDA
you got fired
for finding this
so what would you recommend for somebody
today 30 years old
145 pounds with cystic fibrosis okay
well this is very simple stuff need to
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat no running around notes
no sugar no carbonated treats no
buckwheat
then
um I'd go for both the brothers
um 100 and
um let's see they need two healthy
branded heart packs from the full
serving twice a day MSM two bottles a
month second take three breakfasts three
months through dinner time that's going
to support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone makes up on itself they
need our ultimate enzymes because the
pancreas is involved here so they need
the ultimate enzymes to take two of
those say five or ten minutes for each
meal a couple ounces of water and then
they also need the vitamin D3 take three
of those twice a day to make sure
everything is turning right
um they need the
um let's see here I'd also go with the
ultimate daily classic tablets two
bottles a month so you take three
breakfasts through dinner time and it's
going to support and promote healthy
blood flow to the brain to the heart
through the kidneys and through your
legs and arms the rest of the body
in
let's see here I would also throw in one
more thing that's the synaptive take
three of those twice a day now that'll
deal with the depression
um an anxiety that goes along
with this with the CF okay so that
covers all the bases from getting rid of
the bad stuff to taking all the good
stuff giving the body what it needs to
repair itself
um yeah and of course I was a recipient
of the cloud Schwartz award very
prestigious award it's kind of like the
Nobel Prize in Biochemistry
um Kyle Schwartz was a guy who
discovered the essentiality of the trace
mineral selenium and there are so many
awards associated with that uh I was
they only have
one or two
recipients
um a year
no uh and nominated and only one every
couple years actually get the award I
think there's only been like four or
five people including me at the clown
Schwartz Awards very prestigious it's
like the Nobel Prize about chemistry so
I'm very proud of that and again for the
same thing in other issues plus I
received as you pointed out earlier the
um Lifetime Achievement Award from the
United Nations
and I was nominated twice for the Nobel
Prize I didn't get I didn't get awarded
the Nobel Prize but to get nominated
twice by universities so I'm very proud
of that just to get nominated is a big
thing but I did get the Kyle Schwartz
award and I did get the Lifetime
Achievement Award from the from the
um United Nations very proud of that
so
um those things tell you that I'm
working on the cusp I'm working on the
fiery Leading Edge of what people need
to maximize Health and Longevity
reproduction and so forth this is not a
simple thing in these modern times
okay because there's a big difference
between maximizing growth of crops and
maximizing nutrition okay there's a big
difference between the two
um they can kind of run parallel with
each other but you can you can grow a
lot of crops don't have much nutrition
because plants only need three minerals
we need 60.
and so with that said I'm going to turn
it back to you
well Dr Wallach myself and my co-hosts
Ruth Ruth Ellen Sanchez nasima Omar
Heather Bowen and Dr Judy Reynolds we
are proud to be on this Crusade with you
and getting the information out to the
masses Dr Wallach
thank you everybody for joining us here
on askdoc live we greatly appreciate all
of you being here live
yeah there you go so that's the Lifetime
Achievement Award that's a picture of
you and the United presenters yeah the
main office in New York
the United Nations
awesome so very fantastic everybody
make sure that you go to askdoclive.com
you will find all of our past replays
from our programs there get back with
the person that invited you to watch
this program whether you're here live
with us or watching the replay and if
you are part of our subscriber base and
nobody specifically
reap or invited you here go ahead and do
a reply to that email that you received
and one of our certified holistic health
coaches will get back with you if you
have not heard a reply within 36 to 72
hours send us another email we are being
more intentional about checking the spam
there's been a lot of funky stuff going
on with emails and if we have not gotten
back to you we do apologize for that but
you have been watching askdoc live we
will see you next year next year happy
New Year everybody happy New Year yes
bye bye be safe leave the carbonated
drinks happy New Year
and if if you have to take part in any
type of spirits and drinking rebound is
a really good mixer just wanted to add
that in there not that I'm going to do
it but
um I've heard reports so everybody have
a great great rest of 2022 and we will
see you next year in 2023
bye for now bye-bye